Jody Foster The Silence of the land I'd
like to dedicate this award to all of
the women who came before me who never
had the chances that I've had and the
survivors and the pioneers and the
outcasts and my blood my tradition and
I'd like to thank all of the people in
this industry who have respected my
choices and who have not been afraid of
the power and the dignity that that
entitled me to of course the reason that
I'm here yeah Anthony Hopkins quid br qu
doctor and my Guru Jonathan Demi and
most of all I'd like to thank my mother
Brandy my friend the person who has
loved me so much and so well that she
taught me an inimitable little manate
Fashion To Fly Away thank you and thank
the academy for embracing such an
incredibly strong and beautiful feminist
hero that I am so proud of thank you
very much Mike and Carol you won the bet